miami is a global destination city it's
a curator of culture really for the rest
of the world
this is a place people want to be it's a
place they want to come and so you take
formula one and you bring it here to
miami and you've got quite a combination
my role as a managing partner of the
grand prix is really putting a great
team of people together to execute on a
vision to turn this place into a global
entertainment destination now with this
stadium we're bringing in formula one
racing right here in miami
really the first priority was to have a
great circuit for great racing
a circuit that drivers love to drive on
that fans love to watch great racing on
so we've tried to create a race track
that has a lot of challenges for a race
car driver you're talking about a
straight away on the back stretch that's
you know almost a mile long
and then you've got some very technical
corners that you've got to navigate
through
but one of the reasons i think formula
one liked it was the idea of a blimp
shot for television looking down at
yachts
so we want to deliver the yacht club and
the marina so that people can watch the
race from the back of a yacht
you got to always have the right goals
in mind in the end which is really to
try to create great experiences for fans
that's unlike anything else they've
experienced
trying to get this racetrack built
logistical challenges were significant
we got 171 temporary structures 65
independent kitchens we've wired the
whole campus with 5g technology
it's been an amazing endeavor to do in
11 months while you're having dolphins
football games and enrolling loud
hip-hop festival in a miami open tennis
tournament
it's been quite a challenge it's been a
fun challenge and again we have a great
team of people and we're looking forward
to having the race
[Music]
there's a lot of things that have
changed the last five years that have
driven fan support and new fans drive to
survive certainly being one of them
they're learning the story lines they're
learning about the drivers there's a lot
of fans now that are interested in
formula one that weren't before because
they see that these are the most
technologically sophisticated racing
machines on the planet these are the
best drivers on the planet
i hope that it becomes one of the
signature races on the calendar for
formula one that people want to come to
i hope that it brings a lot of economic
value obviously to south florida which i
know it will there's an economic engine
that comes into the city from around the
world to experience this event it's
really like having a super bowl every
year for 10 years
and most importantly i want to really to
impact people's lives look at kids in
this community who don't know formula
one now we'll be exposed to it we have
stem programs going on in the schools
hopefully some of these kids 10 years
from now are engineers or marketing or
communications professionals or
otherwise involved in formula one in
some way because we brought this race
here
this is a global sport that has always
been there but i think in the united
states people are just starting to fall
in love with it in a new way
[Music]